it might look like dressing up but for
cosplayers this is a very serious
business it becomes a bit of an
obsession once considered a niche
pursuit cosplay has moved into the
mainstream in recent years thanks to the
proliferation of superhero films and
fantasy franchises now most of us would
struggle to keep a straight face in some
of these outfits but this weekend 24 of
the world's best cosplay creators will
be coming down to the serious business
of competing in the European cosplay
Championships and there's controversy
before anyone's even brandished a
Warhammer
this is French cosplay champion Alice
live in heart whose entry has been
banned from the final after accusations
that her costume Pike from League of
Legends was the equivalent of blackface
they wanted to be as accurate as
possible because I love that character I
really do love him just the way he is I
mean I don't want it to change anything
he is black he should be black that's O
most characters you'll see here are
entirely fictitious but judges at this
year's event say it's still wrong for
competitors to wear a skin tone that's
darker than their own cosplay is for
everyone and if it is for everyone you
know we should give platforms and
really good representation to our
cosplayers of color within the cosplay
community people have been getting
rather animated about the issue it's
unfortunate that it sort of turned into
a fight instead of one day from
listening to cosplayers of color in a
perfect world you can cost for who you
want but we're in a perfect chord we
can't have to like be aware of like the
way the world is right now while there's
no doubting the technical skill behind
some of these elaborate costumes
organizers say it's important to lead by
example that it's not okay for a fantasy
costume to cause real world's offense
Katie Spencer Sky News